um let me ask you this do you feel like
the way because I I feel like the Pat
McAfee thing happening and then all of
this these Cuts happening and Stephen A
starting his own show I feel like none
of these are coincidental oh no it's not
right I'm like okay well they had to pay
this guy however much they had to pay
him for him to walk away from that
FanDuel deal which shout out to him for
yeah being comfortable enough to do that
but at the same time you got oh look
Stephen A launches his own thing on
YouTube like do you feel like Pat McAfee
in the same way that Skip and Stephen a
kind of changed what moves the needle in
traditional TV ratings on Sports
networks with debate by the way PTI was
the first to kind of do that but
um Do You Feel Like Pat McAfee's
changing the sports broadcasting
industry yeah he's he's the one that
shows the proof of concept the best in
sports
um you know you combine that with the
Paul Brothers you combine that with Joe
Rogan yeah yeah everybody starts getting
crazy right but in sports like it's
McAfee
um and the beautiful thing is I I keep
going back to it he didn't even raise
his hand to do it but you know what he
was doing he didn't know it
um he was falling in an alignment where
the industry had to go so let's go way
back to like 98.99 when Bill Gates first
said content is King and everyone's
heard that right but we didn't really
understand it because we didn't have the
proper mediums and the proper conduits
to do that so content is King before
social media is really big meant what I
stay in the studio longer my show is
longer what's content is Keen but what
he really meant then and I was just at a
summit speaking in Silicon Valley about
this where all the tech Guru CEOs are
talking VCS now that this world
especially Sports media is going to
change and morph into everyone is a
Creator and everyone is a channel now
some people are already pushing back
probably thinking I ain't a channel I'm
not a Creator everybody is if you got an
Instagram well no let's go
content creator technically yes if
someone is following you that's giving
you attention if you post something
someone's given that some sort of
attention you might get two likes there
you go that is content you may get two
likes but if you talk about interaction
engagement did someone slow down on it
right there yeah because that's what
they look on the back here they're
trying to measure those metrics and
they're like oh that was interesting
okay now we're going to change your feed
your algorithm for that point being you
are a creator
on a grander scale that is Pat McAfee he
just started to plug away during a
three-hour show every single day and
falling into alignment where everything
had to go so now everything is going out
and very unedited very unhinged when it
came to the language he's using it it
was like oh this guy doesn't work for
nobody so he could say whatever the [__]
he was he wants and it was sick and I I
mean and he played you know I'm watching
one of my contemporaries doing the same
thing broadcasting right play ball like
I did and then I'm watching him in a
tank top curse about the same topic that
I'm over here hello in a suit you look
at all Prima price it's like who who's
the fans going to want to see they want
to see the uncut version of that or
right I wanted to see yeah so I'm like
you know getting off the studio desk
everyone is bowing down to me oh look
marcelon TV linear cable respect which
it is of course of course it's a
different animal if it wasn't Pat McAfee
wouldn't be on ESPN if it didn't matter
because it does still matter because he
he took he's he a lot of people think he
walked away from you know maybe a little
bit more money no they got that wrong
too oh did they let me tell you all
right so let's just say the FanDuel deal
is 120.
if it's 120 that's what they reported
and then it gets 85 from ESPN everybody
already initially kind of ran with it
the wrong way
120 from FanDuel is here Pat do
everything else with it pay every pay
yourself
yeah pay the whole crew whoever Rox man
Jones everybody all of them yeah and run
that operation and you deal with all
that tax attorneys yeah or I give you 85
and then we pay your crew and then I go
AJ come here you come in here next
nobody talking about his deal AJ here's
your five-year 25 whatever it may be so
everybody starts getting that it grows
greater than the 120 he got from FanDuel
and everybody's secure everyone gets
their health insurance through somebody
it ain't on Pat McAfee's diamonds Etc
all these things the benefits like it's
insane so he took a better deal on top
of a grander platform and he's gonna be
able to so much if he just hosted the
ass piece you know like they threw him
in last minute last minute and he killed
it he killed it that's that's the thing
like he still gets to do what he's doing
but he also gets that turbo boost that
nitrous from ESP by the way shout out to
AJ Hawk for never having to leave his
house and and just they somehow did such
a good job because you know I'm so
against Zoom content like when we do
interviews and stuff for the most part
if something yeah I noticed that when we
were setting it up you're like bruh if
somebody came up like look like if if
Drake was like we have to do it all
right
I'm just I mean like you're what you're
but you're in town you know like I think
we've maybe done two or three Zoom
interviews in the last three years I
think one of them was uh
Tyrese you let Tyrese off the hook he
from L.A no man we did that more for the
radio Drake got a spot in L.A too so who
you letting off the hook these people
these cats live in L.A dog TLC
uh but yeah it wasn't what was the other
one oh yeah and then like uh but for my
[__] I think that's the only two like oh
and then goodie mop they were in Atlanta
and it was middle of the pandemic oh
okay so this was like early pandemic
they don't dance no more okay I'll give
you some of that but but but they've
done a good job of figuring out a way to
make the remote thing work oh your ESPN
does that everybody they do nobody even
notices anymore yes because I think in
the hip-hop space people notice really
yeah like when you're not doing like an
in-person interview in the music space
people notice that's a great Point
Sports we're so used to seeing everybody
Mike wilbon's in Arizona or yeah he's a
conditioner cornhusers in DC and no one
yeah and so like you know just let's
kind of finish your point and finish
what we were talking about
everyone's gonna become a Creator you
already are but it's going to become
like you're gonna lean into it and
really realize that's who you are even
if you're an old lady just sitting there
showing pictures of your grandkids
you're a Creator what comes from that
is now you're going to all understand
you have to license that out
um and what ESPN just bought into was
the first licensing of a Creator yeah so
they now it's a proof of concept on
YouTube second most Googled which Google
owns YouTube but second most used search
engine is YouTube right behind Google
which owns YouTube yeah so what they are
doing is they're like ah we're creating
what has to be created with your
creators right now traditional media
whether that's linear cable or
traditional media has to now buy into
all of us because we are where the
people are so reason I took off my suit
ultimately is I was making 1.9 million
dollars I hate this world we can't tell
kids and people how much you're making
like in football everybody know how much
you make right everybody everybody they
know every little detail every little
Clause yeah point zero well you know if
it makes it Pro Bowl this year that's an
extra 500k or Kyler Murray has to study
right and then I get it that was funny
um these thin like these these like
fragile egos or fragile industry well we
saw a lot of these salaries the guys who
just got fired and you're like God yeah
I'm like why are we High guys like
Keyshawn Johnson was eating not not was
he signed a five-year deal and only did
one year of it he's getting paid for the
next four years when I saw the Keyshawn
Johnson number and listen the morning
show was decent it wasn't great Keyshawn
is a decent on like like obviously a
legendary player he's done a great job
dog that's not a dog yeah listen L.A
Legend SC Legend oh here come my butt
when I saw that number I was like oh you
forgot Keyshawn always hit him over the
head oh there was a football contract
his agent
I think he's his own agent whoever
agency is negotiating his [__] I said oh
man good for him but you know the real
of that is he got that deal
God let me let me untangle this for
y'all so max is making that big first
take money right then they're like all
right Stephen A and him ain't going
right mix water and oil they ended up
putting Max on with Keyshawn right yeah
yeah that morning show yeah so this is
how it is Keyshawn was already there
they got rid of the Zubin guy right he
got sick and then it just left something
like that so then Max comes in but Max
making first take money that's the most
expensive morning show ever right for a
radio show right at all time so did
Keyshawn sitting there like um he came
to my hood this my show whose name is
first Keyshawn yeah so he used that as
leverage that's how he got that though
oh yeah it's games so if you were making
you were making 1.9 I was making 1.9
which is you know I mean like I'm in a
minus territory most that's great though
most people you see don't make that and
you were were you being were you in LA
or you were going to uh Connecticut L.A
okay all L.A which was great it was a
great fit for my life it's just it I
plateaued first of all I'm the realest
it's just like being an athlete I knew
when I was sorry right now everyone else
will say it before me but I acknowledge
it when y'all saying it too when an
athlete's coming down the hill he knows
it he just ain't gonna admit it he won't
admit it everyone else is gonna say it
so I knew I would Plateau because the
three big dogs in my industry I never
could be like them and that's a positive
for them and just a difference from me
Stephen A Skip and Colin so this is how
I look at life man it's the science of
life I'm like all right all three of
them didn't play at the highest level
so there's a different level of
communication and investment right then
I'm like all right they all go places I
wouldn't go because I'm not trying to be
condensed into that great headline
that's spicy I don't go in on the camera
you'll notice a lot less of the crueler
takes coming from actual people who
played right exactly so I was like damn
I'm not a hot take artist
um and people think that's with a
negative connotation I'm like no that's
just a brand we're all in the circus
just different tense my tent is not that
so I was like so how much can I make in
my tent now start looking around like
think you making the most in this tent
bro so I was like do you bet again my
next negotiation was going to be a
haircut using the pandemic and of course
all this stuff so I was like then I'm
looking at my neighbors I'm like these
suckers are going downstairs in these
content houses destroying life and
moving in next to me so I was like all
right we talked through the negotiation
basically
I started my own show downstairs in my
house I'm just going downstairs so it
was your decision to leave FS1 so yeah
so that's on your own terms both times
Well if they would pay me 10 million but
both times leaving ESPN and FS1 you left
on your own oh yeah like there well
there are other opportunities and shows
for me to go there yeah no but you you
were like hey I'm gonna move on to FS1
because I have a a place where maybe I
can showcase who I am more yeah and then
once the FS1 thing ran its course yeah
free agency like you got other offers
are they better offers my mind at
leaving FS1 was this
there was three levels of me Landing the
plane the first one was we're not doing
speak for yourself anymore because
whitlock's not here who designed that
whole show he was there from the
beginning well you're there when it
became you weren't there when it became
speak no no that's when I was out
because they were telling me about that
right and I was like damn I'm going
backwards in life no slight to them
because I already did Sports Nation and
I was like I've already done the the
four person panel all that you've been
there done and they're done that the top
layer we're going to talk about Cowboys
we're going to talk the Lakers I've done
that and I was like damn I got so many
more muscles to flex that I won't get
the flex in that format on this show but
they paying you so much they're paying
you to be in that velvet coffee right
right like just just die slowly with us
shut up you know what I mean and so I
was like damn
level two was the fact that the offer
wasn't going to be as Grand as my
imagination of being out here being on
YouTube letting Brands plug into me
sponsors plug into me going direct to
Consumer and number three was frankly we
start talking about other shows building
the show out in my home which we started
um first things first which I love but
it's in New York it was conversations of
it coming to La it didn't happen then I
was like now I'm going I'm chasing money
because the only reason I'm gonna do
this is because they're paying me I
would never want to be in New York away
from my kids I would never want to go
over here and be away from my kids and
just travel and do the circuit I
right but I don't want to do do that and
then you know using my network and
knowing what I know and wanted to lean
into my Foundation I said you know what
Just Do Your Own Thing regain do the
work man yeah it won't come and then
let's roll and then YouTube's doing well
it is man and you you guys I mean almost
six months do you have
um somebody handling your brand
Partnerships and your sponsorships or do
you do a lot of that yourself or do you
yeah someone's handling it but I I mean
I'm always cc'd I'm always chiming in uh
you know only I know my own secret sauce
did they get your Bluetooth yet the
Bluetooth are you Bluetooth up yet what
is that you got to get that Bluetooth
man what is that they sponsor our show
oh is that some food or something dipped
uh it's like a dick pill
my wife said get it get it everywhere
get that boy the ingredient is virus
yeah let's use the promo code bootleg oh
and you'll get a month for free it's
smooth with that okay